foreign
[Music]
welcome to Google Cloud next 2023 are
you enjoying the conference so far
awesome great welcome to the session I'm
Vidya shanmagam
I'm product lead in bigquery and I have
it near valued customer Albin who's
coming all the way from France here he's
the director of engineering at teeds say
welcome to Alvin thank you for joining
us
great audience thank you
so before we jump in I just want to
quickly share what we'll cover today so
you can see how this relates to what
you're thinking about
we'll first talk about some of the great
Technologies we have here in Google
Cloud uh that power cross Cloud
analytics and workloads including
bigquery Omni and looker we also have a
cool demo to Showcase some of these new
features we have as well as cross-cloud
joins and governance with dataplex
integrated
and saving the best of the last we hear
from our customer teams on their journey
to bigquery and bigquery Omni from
redshift
so let's jump in
let's start with data right this is a
data analytics session so let's start
with some numbers here over the last
decade we've seen a massive explosion in
data both in data types data volume
if you look at numbers in two years
we're going to be hitting 120 181
zettabytes I had to Google what a
zettabyte is and it's one followed by 21
zeros it's such a large number it's uh 1
trillion gigabytes so very very massive
whereas all of this data coming from
from all of your applications from apis
whether it's transactional systems
whether it's streaming or whether it's
any form of batch processing systems and
with this volume and explosion of data
and different types of data it's sitting
in different data silos and storage
systems whether it's warehouses whether
it's data Lakes object stores relational
databases and more and more customers
are also having this data spread across
multiple Cloud platforms majority of our
customers and Enterprises we talk to
they have data sitting in multiple
clouds did you all know that 9 out of 10
organizations they fail in their
multi-cloud strategy nine out of ten
organizations this was very very
shocking to me as you know as a PM
working on this area and that's why
we're all here to talk about multi-cloud
analytics and learn some best practices
so let's dig deeper into these
Technologies
so how does looker how does bigquery
omni all of these things come together
we talked about customers wanting to
manage their data silos they want to do
more with their data sources here and
more and more customers want to combine
them understand the end-to-end data for
Data Insights for their analytics needs
with bigquery Omni you're able to
consolidate your data into a single pane
of glass for your query for your
analysis for your data transformation
for all your needs with looker on top of
this Consolidated data then you have a
robust consistent semantic layer you can
visualize you can explore your data and
with this you power all your data
experiences all your different workloads
so what is bigquery sorry clicker on the
wrong direction what is bigquery Omni
many of you might have heard or tried
bigquery Omni but I'll give a little bit
of what what the nuts and bolts of this
solution are
bigquery Omni is a fully managed
serverless bigquery offering that's
running on AWS and azure what it
essentially is compute that is running
local to your storage so it's accessing
your AWS S3 buckets or your Azure blob
store directly without actually moving
without actually replicating any form of
data with this you have a single pane of
glass to query your data at ease you're
also able to do a lot of cross-cloud
joins cross-cloud materialize views
which I'll talk about soon with all of
this data sitting in different places
you also want security you want
governance and bigquery Omnia loves you
to do a consistent and unified
governance across all of your data sets
here
so let's see with an example how the
single pane of glass works right in this
example I have a fictitious gaming
company who has several titles and
player data sitting across AWS S3 Azure
blob store bigquery managed storage as
well as GCS these are all disparate data
sources they're all physically located
in different locations but what Omnia
loves you to do is see it all in the
single bigquery interface it all acts as
if these are native bigquery tables we
are not replicating data we are not
copying any data we're just providing
you access to that data by bigquery
compute running in these locations which
means for data analysis for anything
with a single SQL statement you're able
to access all of this this is as we've
talked with several customers super
powerful because instead of you having
to go into each of these platforms and
query your data move your data through
data pipelines we're giving a single
pane of glass single axis and what more
you can also set row level column level
access current roll and fine-grain
access on these data sets here
now next I know it's very cool to go and
look at all your data at a single pane
of glass and maybe run ad-hoc queries
but that's not enough right you want to
combine this data you want to do a lot
more with that data and cross Cloud
analytics is where that comes in so we
have several capabilities in our
portfolio for organizations to do cross
Cloud analytics and I'll be talking
about some of them here today so
starting out with cross-cloud
Transformations so you might want to
query the data you might want to locally
transform them and bring bring only data
set that you need for bigquery for
further analysis so we have a capability
called cross Cloud transform that allows
you in a single SQL statement query your
AWS data or Azure data pre-process them
filter them and then create a table in
bigquery directly in one statement so
whether it's a new table that you want
to create or you want to append to an
existing table we support both of those
operations
now we are very very excited
I need to figure out how to turn the
clicker in the right direction sorry
about that
um so we're very excited to announce a
very very net new capability called
cross Cloud joins
cross-cloud joins is a single statement
direct cross Cloud join join between two
clouds so in a single SQL query you're
able to now join a table that you have
in AWS or Azure and the gcp table
no other cloud data warehouse vendor
offers this capability this is something
we're doing by running sub queries on
your behalf in the AWS data set bringing
only the relevant data you have here and
joining it
how many of you are excited about this
capability
awesome thank you we have this in
private preview for you to try it out
okay talked about cross-cloud transforms
I talked about cross-cloud joins great I
can ad hoc query some things but what if
my data is changing what if I want
periodic dashboarding periodic reporting
I want to power up local dashboards that
I want to use for my business analysis
or executive reporting how do I do this
right I'm running ETL pipelines I'm
bringing my data periodically what do I
do and so we have a net new capability
here called cross Cloud materialized
views that allows you to do just this
what cross Cloud materialized uses
allows you to set up a local
materialized view in AWS you can specify
your refresh intervals based on how
often your data is changing and then you
can create a remote materialized view or
cross-cloud materialize view in gcp once
you have that materialized view now
available in bigquery and gcp it's
accessible to the entire gcp ecosystem
you can run analytics you can use it
with dashboarding bqml AIML any form of
operations are now available here so
this capability is recently launched
available in private view as well for
you to try out
now we talked a little bit about single
pane of glass we talked about
cross-cloud analytics what about
governance several of your organizations
you think deeply about security managing
your data data thinking about access
controls so we have a very very tight
integration with data catalog and
dataplex and that's what I'm going to
talk to you here today
with integration with data catalog
you're able to like seamlessly search
your data discover enrich it with
metadata with business glossary you're
also able to do fine-grained governance
with row level access and column level
access and we have in the future
governance rules coming which will allow
you to do this at scale
lastly we also support lineage so
whether your data is in gcp sitting in
AWS or Azure once it's a big lake table
you can run lineage on it you can track
and understand your data assets so the
governance is not isolated the
governance is cohesive it's unified it's
consistent no matter no matter where
your data is
wouldn't it be cool if all of these
capabilities I'm talking about is
available in a region close to you so
bigquery on these Regional rollout we're
rapidly expanding into several new
regions and very happy to say we have
Global coverage with our recently
launched APAC regions and Europe regions
this summer just a few weeks ago we
launched the EU Dublin region in Ireland
we also launched the U.S west region in
Oregon we have several more regions
launching later this year so we have
Global coverage and we're continuing to
expand
I just won't spend too much time on the
slide but what I want to share is that
we've heard your feedback we've heard
our customers talking about how
cross-card analytics needs to be more
powerful more performant and so this is
a set of capabilities our team's been
hard at work in launching in the last
several months we talked about the
joints the materialized views we also
now Federate from AWS glue catalog if
that is your source of truth and you
want to keep that in sync that's
something we support here we have query
acceleration and performance
acceleration now we support we have
support for analytics Hub in Omni
regions I didn't put this on the slide
but we also support Iceberg and Delta
format on Omni here so with that we have
several new capabilities for you all to
try it out
now how does this all come together we
talked about all of this Technologies
but I want to bring this bring this all
together before we jump into it sure
right our goal in gcp is to provide a
cohesive cross-cloud analytics platform
which means there are multiple building
blocks starting out with bigquery Omnia
talked about how it consolidates your
data across clouds in a single pane of
glass with big lake table integration we
have fine-grained governance providing
row level column level access for all of
your cross-cloud analytics for fresh
consistent data we have materialized
views we have cross-cloud joins now that
your data is all Consolidated in BQ and
gcp then the power is yours right with
looker with ML models with vertex CI you
can do anything with your data so now
you're taking the organizational data
that's all siled which is you know not
spread across different places to now
come together to power your analytics
and insights for your organization
I'll pause there with that I'm going to
jump in we will have time for Q a later
in the session so if you have any
questions please think about it we'll
jump in there um so with that
I do want to show some demo and some of
the cool features we've talked about as
well as talk about our unified
governance here
let's see
great I did pre-record this demo because
we did want to cover several different
features and we want to bring that
together in this short session here uh
so what we will be seeing here is a
discovery experience so as a data
analyst for a fictitious organization I
know that a symbol here I know that I
have orders data sitting in AWS and I
want to be able to go and discover that
data what I'm looking to do here is I'm
going to then go into
sure if this is playing just give me a
second oh it is playing okay
um so yes I'm going into the discovery
being here and I'm going to look for
order items data here and what you can
see is on the right side this data and
the stable is coming from AWS like I
talked about it's in a different Cloud
here I'm going to quickly look at the
schema for this and this makes sense for
me I'm going to pause here for a minute
to just talk about the joins capability
that we had
so I talked a lot about cross-cloud
joins and I want to show how real it is
here right so as an analyst I know I
have orders data that's sitting in AWS
this is my point of sale data I have all
my e-commerce data in a bigquery table
in gcp and for me to be able to like
look at my holistic organization look at
my holistic order data I need some
Fields sitting in AWS I need some other
fields sitting in gcp and before this I
would have to actually run ETL pipelines
move my data bring that to gcp for me to
do that now what we are showing here is
in a single SQL statement you're able to
pull the fields that you need from your
AWS table pull the fields you need from
your gcp table and through a left join
actually create a Consolidated data set
so this is the power of the Cross Cloud
joins that you all applauded me here for
so let's jump in and see how to create
this thing it's going to run here in a
minute
let's see
so now it's processing and once the
table is created you can see that I have
Fields sitting from AWS and Fields that
are here in gcp all in one Consolidated
table then that's available in gcp for
me to use as I mentioned it can use it
with any of the dashboarding tools of
your choice you can use it with bqml
your ml models you'll you can take it to
vertex AI for your training now I've
looked at the schema looks good to me
all the fields that I wanted from my
different sources are here
what if I want to do more governance
aspects with it I want to profile I want
to do data quality and all of those
features are something that I'm going to
show here right so I want to understand
that my data that I got from two
different sources as an analyst I don't
know what's in that Source it's
statistically distributed it's not too
skewed so I did a quick data profile
scan this does take a little bit time to
run but we fast forwarded here to the
demo so you can see that uh it's the
quality is fine for me what I'm going to
then do is I'm going to set up data
quality rules I want to make sure that
as new fields and new rows are coming in
they match a set of criteria here so
here are some data quality rules that
have been automatically generated based
on the profile we run so you saw that
with recommendation space so I didn't
specify it and there are some fields for
null check there are some fields to say
hey should meet the set of criteria here
for one of these fields so these are
automatic rules that have been set on
the combined data just based on
recommendations without much effort from
your end it automatically pulls said if
you're happy you can create this data
quality rule make sure that any data
that's coming in matches this we have a
scorecard which talks about how many of
these rules have passed how many of
these rules have failed and will give
you automatic alerts as well if you set
that up uh so that's a bunch of things
related to like profiling quality checks
now I want to do fine-grained governance
right uh so if you jump to that part of
the demo here
I want to set row level access to a
specific group to just say these are the
fields that I really want this user to
be have access to no other field so I'm
setting a row level access here saying
that one of this fields of the terminal
status is what should it return I run
this and on the Consolidated table I
would be running this as an admin it
will set that rule level access policy
now let's go query this table and see
what it's going to return for us
when I go query this table you can see I
already see a flag that only a subset of
rows are returning and then the fields
that are here are matching the rule
levels that I've set it's only giving me
access to that and all the other fields
are hidden from me so this is powerful
row level and column level
jumping further into lineage so the
Consolidated table we know has data from
gcp and data from AWS so what you can
see here is telling me the source and
the flow for the data so in this case
this table is from gcp going further to
the order tables this is the one that we
got from AWS here and if you see here on
the right side it's S3 bucket that the
source of the data it's a parquet file
so I not only can profiles can set
governance but I also can understand the
lineage of my data and continue to track
it lastly what we're going to show is
now I want to share this data with my
organization so I want to enrich it with
some metadata I can set a bunch of
different fields whether it's
description whether it's labels whether
it's expiration time so once I set all
of these fields now I have my data set
and ready to go and can be shared so
this is kind of the end of the demo but
what I want to um
quickly talk about we saw a bunch of
different things here
um what I want to share here is that we
started out with just knowing that there
is a data set in AWS we searched for it
we discovered it we knew this is the
data set we won and then through cross
Cloud join we took data from there and
from gcp created a Consolidated table we
ran data profiling and we had automatic
data quality saw the dashboard there
then we did uh row level and column
level security here we saw row level
with fine-grained governance we also saw
the lineage capabilities and then
metadata enrichment so all within this
five minute demo you saw how with
bigquery with Omni together we were able
to do cross-cloud analytics you're able
to govern uh your data very holistically
so with that I want to transition back
to um Alvin here to come talk about
teach Journey
thank you
thank you Vidya
all of these announcements are really
exciting
and they are particularly on point for
us
kids is no exception to the industry
Trends and to illustrate that I took the
liberty to steal your very first slide
we have a large volume of data it is
increasingly distributed it serves more
and more use cases and it's spread
across all major three Cloud providers
mercero and I've been working at seeds
in Montpelier south of France for the
past seven years
in seven years teeds has evolved a lot
and so has its ability to deal with data
in seven years the two biggest additions
to our data stack were the introduction
of bigquery and Luca
today I give you an overview of this
data Journey what is teeds and why do we
need so much data
the tools and Technology we put in place
including bigquery and Luca
the challenges we have with cost Cloud
providers
and finally our single pane of glass
stream
so what is this
teens provides an end-to-end online
advertising platform
with kids brands are able to reach up to
1.9 billion users
and with kids Publishers can monetize
their content with advertising that
respects their users
now providing advertising to 1.9 billion
users generates a lot of data and it
requires a lot of data too
so data teeds itself two major use cases
the first one is operational
to keep showing relevant ads to the
right users we need to collect data to
train machine learning models and to use
these models predict user Behavior
most of these infrastructure is an AWS
to train those models we use a mix of S3
EMR and Spark
the second major use case is Analytics
we provide data and insights to our
users
to our clients through data exports and
data visualizations
and to our internal users
through a self-service bi platform
analytics is the use case that made us
choose Google Cloud seven years ago
so let me show you a high level recap of
how our data stack has evolved over the
years
so we started with AWS only
with a spark based machine learning
framework
then seven years ago we introduced
bigquery
our primary goal
was to provide a powerful reporting
capabilities to our clients
now to provide data to our customers in
a timely manner it requires
Transformations such as data
aggregations
to do that we introduced DBT a
well-known open source tool that allows
everyone at kids to describe these
transformations in a standard way
these Transformations are then executed
inside bigquery
next we needed to provide data
visualizations in web applications
unfortunately bigquery was not the right
tool for that at the time so it shows
redshift that allowed us to have a lower
latency and to
support a higher concurrency
then a major addition to our business
intelligence capabilities was the
introduction of Luca
it helps every teacher employee to take
data driven decisions
and lastly tech savvy users still have
the options to run direct queries
against the raw data using Athena
bigquery SQL or even spark notebooks
I'll now take a bit of time to present
two of these tools which are bigquery
and local
there would be much to say about
bigquery but in the interest of time
I'll only illustrate with this graph
each line represents the adoption of our
one of our data technology attacks spark
bigquery and redshift
so don't mind the exact figures they are
made up but my point is bigquery is
winning the adoption race at teens
now why do you think is the number one
reason for that
is it more powerful is it cheaper it's
not but it's definitely simpler
it's simpler to learn it's simpler to
use and it's simpler to maintain
as a company and as we grow as a company
it is becoming more and more important
to provide simple tools that can be
adopted by most people and the
Simplicity of bigquery has really helped
us doing that
is our most recent addition to our data
stack
we recently had to change our bi
platform so we compared many tools and
we ended up choosing Lucas here are the
three main reasons why
first is the looker modalization layer
it abstracts the complexity of our
underlying data it is defined as code
and versioned in git and it allows a
centralized governance
the second reason is that it dedicates
the processing to the data warehouse
so it may seem a basic feature but
actually
most of well-known bi platforms are
actually requiring requiring you to
to import all of your data into the into
their system
and finally
Lookers self-service exploration
capabilities
it lets people interact with your models
directly and be able to take data-driven
decisions in a self-service way
unfortunately dealing with multiple
Cloud providers comes with its
challenges here are some of the
challenges we have
the cost of ownerships are free tools
bigquery redshift and Athena
we also have many different ways to
query the data we have looker we have
bigquery SQL we have Athena SQL redshift
SQL or even spark notebooks
and finally we need to maintain jobs to
move and transform the data between
clouds
so we can summarize all of these
challenges into a single one it is
becoming more and more complex to deal
with data
that's why we are now investing into
reducing this complexity our goal is to
rationalize our data stack
the first candidates to this
rationalization is redshift so let me
give you a bit of context on why which
shows redshift on top of bigquery
our goal was to embed data into
interactive client-facing web
applications
we expected low response time and a high
volume of data of queries
unfortunately in 2018 bigquery was not
the right tool for that redshift had a
lower latency for small queries and was
able to
was able to take more concurrent queries
thanks to several small redshift
clusters
I'm glad to say that bigquery has gotten
better since
thanks to several enhancements in the
resource allocation systems and some
features such as the bi engine
it is more realistic to use bigquery for
this use case now
so that's what we do
not only it reduces the complexity our
developers have to deal with but it also
he moves the need to move data between
clouds
so that's where we are today
now what's next
we still have too many ways to explore
the data and we still have too much
closed Cloud complexity
so let me share my vision for the years
to come I'm calling this the single pane
of glass dream
the single pane of glass is a single
simple way to access all the data where
there is it stored on S3 or bigquery
so in this dream we are using Iceberg as
a table format for our S3 data Lake
iceberg is an open source table format
that brings many interesting
capabilities such as acid transactions
and performance improvements
this format is supported both by spark
and bigquery
in this dream it is possible to
cross-cloud to join cross cloud data for
small queries or to easily transfer data
between clouds and of course all of this
data would be accessible in local
so that's it for me thank you so much
Vidya for inviting me on stage and now
I'm counting on you and your team to
deliver on this cross-clad vision and
make this dream a reality
thank you so much Alvin
thank you all for being
thank you for being such a great
audience
[Music]
foreign